tony we'll kick it off with you baby i
hear your voice today i hear the songs
being sung here and i'm talking about
voices because my talk of the table is
about a controversial new feature from
amazon i'm not going to tell you exactly
why it's controversial i just want to
have you listen to a little uh kid asked
alexa to get a story read by grandma
this was at a conference uh just
recently take a look and then i'll
explain okay
alexa can grandma finish reading me the
wizard of oz
okay
but how about my courage
ask the lion anxiously
you have plenty of courage i am sure
answered ours
in this experience
grandma in this scenario is no
longer with us
alexa with this new technology you see
why it's controversial yeah i don't like
it alexa is creating i don't really like
anyone's voice so you can have your dead
relative yes engage i don't like why
don't you like it i don't like it if
you're a child and you're missing your
relative and you want to hear that voice
why not that creeps me out that doesn't
creep you out that creeps me out when my
mom died i'd say the answering machine
back in the day we had answering
machines yeah so i saved the answering
machine where she said this is peggy
king you've reached out of that a lot of
people do that i've saved it yeah and
then i let it go but to have her her
voice reading like she's there is creepy
to me some people don't want to let that
go some people want that to last forever
i understand that i i think a recording
i'm seeing both sides okay well i want
to see your side do you like this idea
if i could hear the voice of a
grandparent that i never had a chance to
meet like a couple of my grandparents i
would love to hear them talk to me i
don't like it but it's a creation it's
an ai creation
it's an artificial intelligence
you take the voice and then they figure
out a way to allow alexa to mimic that i
bet people agree with both of us nate
but they do